Frank Ocean had a complete meltdown on
the the state actually screw it I'm
gonna say it uh I warned everybody about
this Frank Ocean show I said to you when
they when he played Bonnaroo I said this
is one of the worst shows I've ever seen
of Bonnaroo why he didn't seem engaged
he didn't care and he let the audience
sing over him the entire set that's not
really his fault to be honest with you
it was just you know he had one of The
Greatest Albums Of The Year a couple
years earlier in Channel orange but that
set was terrible and it was one of the
most sought after sets we had waited
years for that Frank Ocean set he he
didn't come the year that he did
Coachella so Channel orange comes out
then he does Coachella we're thinking
when the lineup comes oh we're getting
we're getting Frank Ocean we're getting
Frank Ocean we get no Frank Ocean then
he shows up they put him on this tent
which was a
disaster of how many people I've never
seen a show that packed before at this
tent and it was just a mess from start
to finish I've never walked out of a
show that I've been that excited about
before we left halfway through it was
impossible to hear this was all right in
front of you and then he goes and does
the same thing at Coachella
um this guy God love him
but man he doesn't like performing
and it doesn't matter how much money you
give him he's just not going to enjoy it
I think that like it's I don't know
where he goes from here I don't know if
he ever performs again but I do know
that the next album he puts out oh my
God Barry is it going to be something
even you know about my mother knows
about it will be a national headline the
second he puts out the next album so it
may end up being the best things ever
happened to his career
he may be the next big thing because he
just you know the bed on the
Coachella stage
but guess what
yeah he's now household name yeah music
will be great that's good point I hadn't
thought about it that way that's a good
point yeah